hello everybody how is it going hope
you're having a great
tuesday uh it's been a
lovely weekend the longer the better
it's just
i need another few days off to recharge
uh but um besides my needs
for sleep let's talk about some chess
so i'm kind of excited because this
month um
september right can't believe saturday
september but
um for september we have a lot of
exciting events coming up
especially the rapid and blitz and the
chess 960.
i've grown to actually um really like
960 over
the quarantine so i'm gonna be
definitely following those
and um on another news i'm gonna be
playing in us championships
um not this month in october
so i kind of um i'm excited about these
but so i've been reviewing my openings a
little bit
when i get the chance um and
i've been doing a lot of tactics so
i found um i found that like i'm good
with short tactics like i see what's
going on i see the end great
but those kind of tactics that you don't
really see the end
i call them the tall style tactics
because that's how
i've always um remembered him
by like he does these tactics and he
doesn't see the end of it
he doesn't see the advantage he just is
like a cool position he goes for it
so that is um something that i wanted to
show you today
so hopefully this is going to go my way
it's not gonna
keep jumping around but um
so here is the first one i
already hope i have some viewers i
actually can't see how many viewers are
here
i mean well um for those of you who are
here
and are ready to start thinking here is
your first puzzle
these are the puzzles that i show you
for today are actually real life games
and i will hopefully be able to share
the names of the players who did these
cool
games with you later on as well but okay
so
what do you want to do in this position
as black
oh hi tracy here what do you think
these are not easy so don't be
disappointed
if you don't find them um so manu
emmanuel i think after something that
you're gonna do
later on like it feels like a strong
move but
not just yet
oh thank you i've never been to peru but
i have a lot of korean friends
oh orlando never been there either i
really have to travel
i used to travel a lot before college
started since college started i just
traveled between dorms at this point
so anybody has a
knight of six looks interesting
careful knight f6 what do you do if
something like rick h4
so i agree that you should definitely
think about checks
you should always think about checks so
for k1 you should definitely consider
but i don't think that i mean you kind
of need more
than just there's a cool chick
um we could improve the the night i'm
not against that
but i would um i would give you a little
advice that
when i when you're doing tactics usually
not
that much improving it's more like some
sort of
something a little bit more forceful
okay one with idea f3 huh
i think those are interesting or k1 with
idea with f3
but i think we need a little
i don't want to give it out too fast so
you guys mentioned check
you guys mentioned um i just got a
mention of check
that is cool i just got them another
mention
of take grade two
so that's the thing
so let's let's think what what are the
things we can eat
we can eat f2 we could potentially eat
on
h3 but right now taking on h street
doesn't work because of rick h4 right
so how can we weaken the opponent's king
what are some of the things that we
could do to weaken opponent's king
i do like f3 but not just yet especially
because if
f3 what do you do after rook h4
i would recommend to think more about
checks and takes
g5 so i get the point of g5 but what do
you do when you lose your knight
i do like the idea of taking on f2
but i think i think you guys need to do
a little bit more so rook takes f2 king
takes f2 then what do you do
so take take bishop c5 would be cool but
the problem is
um spent so
careful
so again i do like the idea of g5 but
right now you just lose your knight
so let's keep thinking about drip takes
f2 takes f2 king takes f2 then what do
we do
i like queen takes h3 then let's say
so we're attacking the
weird we're attacking g4 so it probably
has to
defend it well hold on you can't start
with queen s3 because rick h4
exactly so you have to take on f2 king
takes f2
then you take on h3 so now for
white um if he moves the rook then it's
already unpleasant because
then you got queen e3 also where would
you put the rook the pawn on d3 is also
falling
you give me a few moves i'm gonna free
my knight and bishop and it will be
pleasant for black
so
how about something like bishop e6 i
think bishop v6 is also
best move for white now what do we do
yeah dennis you're right there should be
six best one
i think there was a slight delay but
yeah
i do like when you treat so queen e3 the
only
i think the only move is the king f1
because if king g2
we have f3 with check right
[Music]
so let's say queen e3
king f1 so question do you guys think
right now
black is like winning is black just
better is it
is it just a fighting game do you think
black made a mistake on the sacrifice
what do you think
black is winning black is lost um
i'm still waiting for a little bit more
but
um so the thing is yes
black does have potentially perpetual
um so i think that's already like a good
good fighting chance like we're saying
okay draw now we're looking for more
so i would give it a good fighting
chance i wouldn't say black is winning i
wouldn't say black is much better
i would say black has more chance at the
moment
but because we kind of have to figure
out how to yeah exactly we're gonna have
to figure out how to
free the night without losing the bishop
so let's say what do you want to do now
are you gonna throw in some checks
are you gonna eat something what do you
want to do so right now after king f1
what do you want to do
if y plays kg2 i think f3 and i i kind
of like this
it feels like it's going well next move
i'm trying
ideally i want to do f2 with check
so kind of depends on what white does
but i think
after after i i i feel more comfortable
compared to king f1
so what do you want to do after king f1
we can't just play f3 right now because
we lose the
d7 check and pick a pond
um i mean i guess we could eat over here
i i think i guess that's all right too
but i think queen c1 is a little bit
more precise
so my idea is with queen c1 well not my
idea
the player named pok p-u-c
king g2 okay so now what do you think is
the best move for black
i didn't i don't think queen takes d3
was wrong i just think um
it's just not the best
way so what do you want to do in this
position are you gonna throw in checks
with the queen are you gonna
um
guess another way to think about it is
is it the right time to
do perpetual ideally we want to do
bishop c5 i agree we got to get the
bishop out but we can't do that right
now because we're pinned
so
but if f3 instead of queen c1
hmm well
that's true if he takes the knights we
have
check we'll push another one we'll make
another queen that's going to be
lovely but i think the thing is if you
play
f3 so your idea are going after this um
this um e2 and you want to give check
but
now white has check and no you have to
play king g7
and i can't take over here
and can i just give check over here
give another check over there this just
feels pretty lost to be honest
right so yeah we have to be careful you
shouldn't allow opponent
to you can't you don't have the luxury
of playing something like f3 and
chilling
because then there's rick h4
so
so i guess queen takes d3 or queen c1
are your only choices or you could try
with queen f3 to do perpetual
but i'm a little skeptical if queen f3
would actually end in a perpetual what
if king goes to g1
clean up here king h2 check
run this is
making me a little anxious i actually
don't want to run this much
actually this is not working glenn is
five mates
but yeah i it's a little hard maybe just
rick g2 queen here
there or bishop h3
yeah i think this could cover up right
yeah and now black faces the issue of
well
can i save my knight and my bishop which
seems to be a little
maybe f3 i mean
f3 i kind of just want to pick my rook
and run
where to go we are g3 so no checks
then f2 or f3
still no checks still have the threats
so you guys see what happens if
black just plays it super chill right so
we kind of need to as black we need to
play it faster to play it forced
so where should we go c1 d3
i think c1 gives a better fighting
chance
so we looked at what happens if we just
throw in check so you throw a check
you throw a check you end up throwing
more check there's going to be a rook g2
and there
your checks will be stopped so you can't
just check check check like that
so like to move what to do
remember how i said these are going to
be complicated tactics
i wasn't kidding these are a little
uncomfortable
a little just it doesn't feel like it's
like tactic tactic
so
so brian we kind of want to throw a
bunch of checks and push the pawn
but we need to find the right
combination and yeah
you guys are correct f3 is the best one
so the thing is
if you take it now i agree queen f1
king g3 now what do you do do you guys
see
any mate do you think this is do you
think you're happy with a perpetual at
this point
or you want to keep pushing for a mate
yeah i agree if queen you can so you
give check king goes to h4
and we do this lovely m82 right
this keeping the square
so yeah i agree so now black white has
to
just agree to this and we're okay with
that
so let's say white wants to push for
more and doesn't take on f3 so let's say
white plays king h2
then how
pond steel
[Music]
not sure what you mean by that we still
are um we are still facing the problem
of work h4
and queen takes d7 with check so we
can't be super chill
uh tracy thinks i'm so chill
right now i am not chill i'm enjoying my
few minutes without stressful for mcat
and exams next week tracy you reminded
me
so
ah queen h6 queenish six is interesting
we stopped rick h4 i like it
what about queen d2 does disney queen d2
works
yeah i think windy 2 is not really good
because king gets three
and then you're kind of giving quite
some chances to run away like you can't
play f2
still the same issues so even if you
can't keep check anymore because of work
h4 as well
so i don't really like this so
queen is six um let's say king goes to
g3 now what
they're kind of auto checks
that is true we could get our knight
activated well not yet because there's a
still rookish force
right so
so we kind of want to free the night but
not not just yet we still have to deal
with other issues
so if you play knight f6
i think um work h4 is pretty much the
only move
check and
i kind of just want to eat over here you
know you're out of checks
your queen is kind of just stopped
you did activate your night but still
not really
it's still the corner so
yeah i'm not really the biggest fan of
this
so let's say anybody thinks of anything
else
besides that knight f6
i would really want to put that bishop
on c5 or even ideally d4
or f42 but we can't do that right away
the bishop is still pinned
yeah i have two nice nice
f2 good
so what if take i think if take when we
have the
lovely perpetual now we don't have to
worry about it right
so what if king goes to g2 i guess at
this point you've all
pretty much realized that most likely
it's gonna we're kind of fighting for a
draw
if not if opponent makes a mistake okay
we'll win
but as long as opponent doesn't make
like a
humongous mistake but we're not going to
be able to win this
so
exactly the pawn was working as a
shelter very well said aryan thank you
ah nice let's get rid of this pawn great
great
understanding we gotta get rid of this
pawn so we can
activate our queen provide all the next
necessary checks um careful not to queen
h6
with jerk h4 oopsie
that this is not a task game no these
are the
his style just because when
i always had this understanding that
when um
tal was making a game making a tactic
during a game
he wasn't necessarily doing it like
because
he saw like up until the end mate he did
it because that's what the position
needed
and that's why i'm showing you these
other games and we can see how this game
white will not be able to run away from
all these lovely checks
and check check check check okay
all right let me
go to the next one
oh please don't crash ah didn't crash
lovely
okay so why to move what should we do
now
okay i see a lot of rookie twos i see
some bishop v8s
at a8s hmm
so anybody anybody has a little longer
line ah thank you
bishop if rookie two bishop takes g2
king e1 okay queen c1
king f2 there's queen f1
because the bishop is on g2 i don't
understand why
rookie 2 bishop g2 you didn't consider
rook takes g2 i understand that you kind
of want to do this rook e8
but it's high um all right i'm gonna
show this line
yeah i don't think your k2 works just
let's take
and
[Music]
take i think take is the best because
just kidding here
what do you do after this
[Music]
i kind of just want to give check and
eat that as well maybe
we'll just eat it over here yeah this
doesn't work
but i do think dirk takes g2 is
interesting the only problem is check
and another check and can you get rid of
all these lovely
checks i don't think so it's gonna be
lots and lots of checks
[Music]
so ah hello
so there was other suggestions
on bishop a8
um
do we kind of so when you're doing
bishop a8 you kind of have to think
about queen takes d2 right
so what do you guys want to do after
take
queen takes d2
what do you guys want to do now do you
think we taking an 8 is good
ah bishop d5 whoa aaron have you seen
this before
you're doing very well bishop d5 is
great yeah
so bishop d5 i think the thing after
bishop d5
is well um
so i see like we can easily
see how um like what white wants
but i think maybe we could also think a
little bit
deeper on if black could get away with
it so
for example what if queen d3
yeah my voice i don't necessarily know
why it's having a little um
background noise it's most of the time
it's fine
sometimes it just gets a little weird
so what now what do you want to do with
your king
king f2 queen e3
isn't there perpetual well that is your
job to
get run away from the perpetual
that's why i'm asking you guys to
basically figure out how to run away
from the perpetual
i think king g2 does look good for a
long walk i agree nicely said
um so kim g2 let's say queen e2 king g3
queen e3
king g4 still trying to do the long walk
what if queen g1
check king f5 queen take queen goes to
g6
check what about that
oh there might be two mics on huh that's
a good advice i'll
i'll look into that tracy i don't think
my desktop mic
was working i just see it
i just see the doors on mic working i
mean
whoa
so we talked about king g2 queen e2 king
g3
queen e3 king g4 queen g1
king f5 you have two options either
queen b1 or queen g6
what if queen b won first
you kind of have two choices either
bishop e4 or king e6 because if your
king goes back to g
then the queen goes to g2
oh so i see yeah i agree kingdom 6 and
white is winning
but what i'm a little surprised
uh queen g6 is check you take it it
takes back with check
you can't just take bishop on f5 oh boy
so we gotta take that guy let's say rook
f8
and this was actually happened in a real
game
so i really like how this happened
yeah the sound i can't help the sound
sorry guys i
sometimes it's okay some days it's
having issues
i i tried to
untangle the cables as suggested
that didn't help that much
i think it's my computer fan
it's just overworking when i stream
so we can see that white is better just
how are you going to win it
what's the what's the move you want to
do
i agree f5 is f7 is the best
because if we did something like
bishop e4 then with g8 right
and then the rook jumps below and if you
move it
hold on
you go over here ah if you push it
i'll take it and then i still have king
king g7
so we'll see we'll see how it's going
but i don't really necessarily like this
i think f7 is just the easiest just
because
no um no rook moves no rook g8s no rocky
eights
so d3 now what d3 is the black's last
hop right
if that pawn didn't exist then then
white is totally winning right
so just um maybe tell me how he would
stop this
yes you have bishop f3 to stop it but
um still it feels like something like
bishop f3 then the rook can't go to c8
still
can't be some jumps how do what do you
think is the most effective way to stop
this pawn
hmm yeah it should be four i think the
24 is the easiest one
d2 bishop c2 you keep your bishop in a
safe spot you're taking care of your
h7 square as well and just bring your
king
with an h4 push that bone right
and okay so this position is super
winning
just need a little bit of more strategy
and skill to win it
so how do you want to win this now
yeah k7 so that's the idea you want to
find the right time to play king e7
you don't want to play king e7 and face
your k7 right
because i mean if you take take
so
what do you think is black's final hope
i would assume the last hopes are some
something along in the queen side right
so let's try to stop them why should we
why should we give opponent
unnecessary hopes
finally eat pawns
but again this is not the only way to
win it's just
like the most accurate way your bishop
is tucked in
taking care of h7 square um
kind of holding these guys together this
pawn
yeah i think this is the easiest way
exactly tracy
finally after months you're learning i'm
proud of you
all right so let me give you another one
ah all right
[Music]
black to move what to do
[Music]
make sure you think about potential
checks
if they work now if they don't work yeah
something like queen is three
the problem with queen history is that
you lose your f3 bishop right queen
takes f3
so you have to identify the potential of
queen edge tree
to see okay so what's wrong with it
queen takes f3
then you think about how you can try and
protect your bishop
or um basically not let opponent take it
when you play queen history
by some means
[Music]
a lot of cafe minute five
um i don't see the move that i see
maybe one two people have said the move
that okay three now
yeah so bishop d5 seems to be the
easiest way
because yeah even if you play knight f5
whoops knight f5 it's still um you're
still leaving some
room for opponents to make decisions
like
what if now i do h4 now i'm stopping
your queenish
tree so you have to do like something
like this so
my point is um
i don't think it's like a bad idea to to
try and defend the bishop again i'm all
for it
but bishop d5 makes more sense you're
attacking the queen you
are simply um kind of like not losing
the tempo you're still like you're still
doing forceful moves you're still
um kind of uh i guess the right
thing is keeping the ball in your court
uh at least that's the expression i kind
of came up with
um in my head i don't know if that's a
farsi expression or
english one but anyways so with bishop
d5 what do you think
now if he takes on g7 queen h3 voila
what about taking out e7 can we still do
queen h3
queen f3 what do you want
no i have a tracy i haven't been
watching sports i've been watching
mcat videos on khan academy and kaplan
and
they they try to make things fun
they try to lessen our pain so
i've picked up some things
in that position with h4 knight h4 does
look
pretty good because he can't take back
there's queen g4
but taking on h4 it's still i'm not
comfortable because they're like little
checks like what if queen
queen would go to e6 check you move the
king then i take on h4 you don't have
queen g4 you don't
well you have queen h4 but it just feels
like you are dragging
it along when you can just try to win
easier like this
so
yeah queen f3 queen f3 seems to be the
fastest way
king f1 what what if rookie for what do
you guys want to do if you have to take
drift to e4
[Music]
we'll probably have to take it right
because we don't we can't really push it
away
so i guess it's logical to take what now
should we take that queen
and go to that end game do you guys
think that end game is winning
yeah you're correct should we easily
check pick that guy up and
b2 is also falling you can't move the
knight it's a winning endgame we
don't need to try to twist our brains
finding a super complicated line that
potentially could give us mate
so okay yep that's about it so what if
king f1
so what now anybody wants to do some
checks
anybody wants to improve anything
i recap it looks interesting but um
so i kind of want to think about more
checks
so how about something a little bit more
checky so i i think again rook f8
i think it's worth thinking definitely
but i don't think
it's the best one so we should
definitely at least think about queen g2
and follow-up checks ah thank you tracy
for queen h1
but i think whatever you can achieve
with queenish one you can achieve with
queen g2 so no no to put her queen in
the line of danger
so now what i do really like the idea of
um
bishop f3 yeah exactly thank you
bishop f3 you have to go to
the line of fire for my other bishop so
let's say king e3
bishop h6 voila king d2 uh
what now should we bring the bishop
should we take on f2
i think those are the two choices
anybody would think between
oh hi esser thank you i'm good a little
swamped
just i already have exams one quiz this
week two exams next week
and my mcat study is going so slow if
there's anybody in the chat who is
pre-med and studied or studying for mcat
every chapter takes like four or five
hours it's just
and they recommend read about do about
20 20 20 to 25 hours a week
and do between one or two chapters a day
and i'm like
the math doesn't add up so if i do one
chapter for four hours let's say that i
do good i do four hours
then i have seven days a week let's say
i do one chapter a day that's already
exceeding the amount of time they told
me to study
so other people read really fast
and just know everything that they're
just like
reading through or yeah
it's been a torture figuring out when to
do what
but yeah
what games am i reviewing surprisingly
i'm not doing a game review
i am doing tall style tactics
alright so i'm glad i shared my current
struggle slash
misery with you guys i usually went more
when we're on the twit channel
so if you want to hear more about my my
life problems
and mcat struggles be sure to tune in
for our twitch channel
oh boy yeah okay i do agree queen f2 is
the easiest way to win queen f2
and rookie 2 is pretty much the only
well
only move i mean you could do queen e2
but if there's rookie 2 i'd highly doubt
people will do that
so rookie 2 bishop h6
king c3 and um
i think the easiest way to win is just
to just put the king in a corner
so queen d4 i doubt anybody would not
play queen d4 i mean i guess if you want
to you can take it but i don't think you
should because then you give your
opponent some chances to
make some problems for you so i wouldn't
recommend this
i would recommend queen d4 and
now you have two choice two kind of cool
choices
either you continue with your check
like bishop d5 or you take on c1
so which one do you want
[Music]
c5 that wasn't one of the options i
don't
know c5 you're trying to do queen b4 uh
check
mates but the problem is when you do
something like so
i think you're thinking good that you're
thinking oh how do you want to do
checkmate and you want to do this
but the problem is when you play c5 what
if something like c3 and i just stop
and i'm attacking your queen so i think
you kind of forgot
that your opponent can make move as well
so let's think about bishop c1 first and
see if we like it
ideally i would recommend to think about
checks first
especially because if something like
king a3 we have this bishop f8 and we
pick up the queen
uh but then we have to think about c4 we
take there's knight c3
we take there is king a4 and we're kind
of running out of checks
so most likely a lot of people at this
point
would um stop their calculation i'm like
okay i can't find
mates i am about to look down
so they would like when they're doing
calculations at this point before making
bishop d5 it's highly likely that they
would stop
and not push after king a4 so
let's look at something like bishop c1
first and it's
it's okay to not push through and come
back and evaluate and see what are your
other options
i don't i'm not telling that you should
just think about that one line and keep
thinking
so um exactly thank you tracy spend your
checks wisely
that's kind of weird to say but yes um
so i think bishop it's a good idea to
take a moment
go analyze the other line come back and
analyze this one
so let's take a moment and think about
bishop c1 so bishop c1
um we want to do queen b2 right so has
to stop
by something like c3 or knight c3 if
knight c3 this is pretty obvious
bishop d5 you take it i have taken on b2
you move the king the
b2 pawn is pinned i have queen c3
so what if c3 what now
the king might also want to run to c2
it's kind of easy to know that as black
you do have advantage
but it's kind of hard to be like okay so
i have advantage but
how do i win
um queen d3 is a little hasty right now
we kind of want that queen to keep keep
an eye on the b2
so we do want this queen b6 king a3 then
we kind of uh we still want the we still
want the idea of
doing stuff on b2 but we can't there's
work on e2
and we can think so is my bishop on f3
actually doing anything useful at the
moment and honestly
it's not so let's eat some material
now the material is actually pretty
equal right and that king on a3 is just
crying
so now um anybody can
figure out a way to improve the position
for black
again it's not like you're finding mate
in like two or three
or whatever but you it's about improving
your position
so how can you improve your position
make sure you think what what do you
think white would do
work left yeah we could bring up the
rook i kind of just want to eat over
here
i don't really necessarily want to deal
with the rook
um other uh yeah whoa
i don't know why my finger slips we
could think about rook d5 as well
but with rook d5 you're trying rig a5
right but check
you have to come back so we could just
simply eat on d3 no knights d2
nobody can touch that bishop on c1
nobody can do nothing
and we actually want to um
i think this is not the time to rush
into it so we can take our time and
improve the position a little
because white doesn't have anything this
is my favorite type of position
that i'm like completely dominating the
position my opponent doesn't have
anything to do no threats no
possibilities
nothing um yeah rick takes d3
if you take it um i can take over on b2
[Music]
i kind of want to take with the bishop
too
the king goes to a4 no never mind i
thought i had pawn b5 my bad
we could do that we could take on a1
if you don't want to deal with the
problems of
problems of material
or you could just keep throwing checks
around
or um
[Music]
this is a very good position so it's i
think you can honestly just take over
here
and you still want to take on a2 as well
right you have b5 your opponent doesn't
have any checks
so anybody anything else here
made in two
how because
thomas i was really appreciative if you
elaborate on what you see
that i don't see ah okay glad to have
cleared up the confusion
but if you're not comfortable with that
you can simply just
play rd5 that's it uh if something
you can do this there's nothing wrong
with it um
you could do more preparation on
bringing the king as well
it's not like he's gonna play knight
here um
my worry was that something like queen
c2 to try and cover up but these are
all better for black as long as you
don't do like a necessarily
um horrible move you should be fine as
black
so as bishop c1 does work so i think
it's a more like a matter of taste if
you want to just
take the material and be like okay i got
the material the king is weak
we'll see how it goes or do you want to
just do bishop d5
so we talked about bishop d5 we said
king goes
sorry we said if king goes away we have
bishop f8 if c4 we can simply take
take and at in this position we kind of
stopped thinking and we took that
little break and we looked at bishop c1
so what do you guys think we should do
in this position
and a little heads up in the actual game
black played bishop b5 and they agreed
to a draw
i don't know what to say
yeah bishop b5 as a draw so if you want
to draw i guess you got it
but do you think you position do you
think you can do more
so bishop b5 is a draw
yeah bishop f8 good job you guys bishop
of f8 yep
if the queen goes to e5 check
check check and mate right
i don't think anybody would have an
issue finding us it's just
straight forward check check checkmate
how about if queen goes to e4 so we
don't have that queen before take
checkmate at the end of the line anymore
how would you win this
so a lot of it is just about continuing
the threads
the rook d4 still queen e8 rook d8 queen
e4 he would just do a perpetual
bishop b5 doesn't work i mean doesn't
work right now just because the king can
go back
you don't have that bishop a4 that you
had remember we talked about if queen e5
then we had check and check and check
and mate
so now we don't yeah jessica good
thinking
queen d6 best one why not b5
um well b5
what do you do after king a5
if queen d6 you want to do mates but
there's a3
it feels like it's kind of just running
away
um i like queen d6 very mature
stopping all the checks um promoting
more checks if you take it i will
definitely do b5 and i'll pick your
queen up as well
so a3 only moved to stop queen b four
so this move is very very strong and
it's very
kind of gorgeous so let's see who can
find this move
after a3 your threads are kind of
stuffed so you have to play it very
smart
in order to not let not allow your
opponent to slip away
so i think i see your idea with c5
but the pro like c5 you want to i assume
play something with queen d7
follow-up or b5 you i guess you want to
do something you want to bring your
queen back to the game right
i see some queen c5s you want to bring
your queen back to the game
however that is not the right way to
bring a queen
because if queen c5 what if i want to
say
um trying to find the move that i want
to say
something like bishop e3
if you do b5 king goes to a5
so summer nice thinking but your plan
has a flaw if
queen d1 take bishop b5 king can't run
to b3
so your ideas with c5 are pretty cool
that you want to bring the queen but
this is the strongest way i didn't find
this move myself when i was thinking
when i was looking at this position
so i'm quite understanding
that it's kind of very hard to see this
move
so the idea is pretty simple it's kind
of a one of those
very tricky sneaky waiting moves if you
take i have b5
no problem if you play something like
rick d2
i'm gonna bring my bishop back and if
you do nothing at all
then i have the c5 check right and you
have to move your king and that's
one step closer to mate so
why not queen c5 if i
briefly mentioned it what would you do
if bishop goes to e3
b5 king a5
then what do you want to do with your
queen your queen will still gonna have
to go
to the not to the side that you want so
queen d7
rook d2 bishop d5
and um if something like queen e5
now we get the check that we want right
we get the check
we get the check and in this position
we have this super cool move of
drum rolls waiting for someone to say it
the idea is clear we want to bring the
kink right
sorry we want to bring the queen right i
don't know why i said king we want to we
want to bring the queen to
attack the king and bring mating threats
bishop c4 is king a7
so king b8 stopping not interesting but
king b8 what if he just takes your d5
so if it's white demon white wants to
take d5 so let's do c6
you take me i'm gonna give you
checkmates easy peasy
and one final line and if queen goes to
e2
we get the c5 that we want that was the
whole purpose of bringing the queen to
d7
pushing the king closer to promotion
and this idea with c6 great
and black is almost there it's
almost winning just few more checks and
this move was also mentioned earlier so
i'm not going to sweat over it
the idea is very simple king b8 i just
want to give you a checkmate
i'm going to keep continue threatening
you with checkmate and if you take here
i'll just give you a check and i'll pick
that guy up
and if queen takes b5 just bishop b7
check
how are you going to get out of it all
right so these are very
very long tactics it was like 20 moves
before you reach the mate
if white did everything correctly
so that's why i called them the thought
style because you don't necessarily know
that you're going to win then it's not
like a mate in two or mating three or
like a very forceful line you still have
a lot of
calculation to do you have to do like
little strategic moves like queen d7
and um it's like when you do the
sacrifice because that's
what the position needed when you're
doing the tactic or
another way to think about it is that
just because you have less material
doesn't mean that you have to do
weird stuff you have to always give
checks you have to always do
something that's super like a
supernatural move
um you can just make normal moves like
queen d7
with idea c5 you can still do normal
things when you have
less material as long as it's keeping
the momentum
um it's yes
this is kind of a forced ish win
um i mean black could make a lot of
mistakes on the way
blight could have went differently and
lost much earlier but yeah overall if
black does everything correctly and
white does everything correctly as well
yeah
black is winning all right so that's all
the time i have for you today i gotta
hand you over to
mr varakopian for some fun end games
i am starting the gym residency from
saturday so you will see a lot more
of me probably on twitch though so make
sure to tune in for that
i believe the club's weekly schedule is
posted and gets updated very frequently
so check that out and with that
note i am going to say goodbye to you
and go study neuroscience